a United Nations at maritime Court says
Russia must immediately free Ukrainian
sailors it's been holding for months and
released their vessels last November
Russia fired on and seized 3 Ukrainian
ships off the Crimean Peninsula has
prompted Ukraine to appeal to the UN's
International Tribunal for the law of
the sea Russia didn't immediately say
how it was going to respond to today's
ruling the confrontation marked a major
escalation of tensions between the two
countries in the conflict over Russia's
2014 annexation of Crimea a Russian
Coast Guard boat last November as it
prepares to ram a Ukrainian naval vessel
that captain can be heard shouting at
his crew to stay the course but the
confrontation didn't stop there
Russia called in fighter jets and
helicopters and shots were fired
wounding some of the Ukrainian sailors
the ships were impounded and the sailors
arrested now six months on Russia is
still holding both the ships and the
twenty-four crew members both sides
blame each other for the confrontation
Moscow says the sailors crossed
illegally into its territorial waters
with weapons on board and ignored
repeated warnings to turn back the men
are set to go on trial and could face up
to six years in prison
Ukraine maintains its ships were in
international waters the incident
occurred in the narrow Kerch Strait
between Russia and Crimea at the heart
of the dispute is Russia's annexation of
Crimea in 2014 which most of the world
views as illegal ever since their
intentions in this region have been high
under a bilateral treaty before the
annexation both countries agreed to
share these territorial waters but
Russia says the agreement doesn't apply
to military vessels Ukraine disputes
that and is demanding the immediate
return of its ships and sailors